party conferences are supposed to be
about uniting the party engaging the
members announcing policies
needless to say accidentally exposing
the mobile phone numbers of everyone
tending isn't it quite part of the plan
so let's talk now to the man in charge
of conference for the Conservatives the
party chairmen Brandon Lewis I've got to
ask you first about what happens with
the Conservative Party app I mean this
is not the start to conference that you
wanted how services are you taking this
oh well any breach of data is a serious
matter that's why we are taking it
seriously though we're investigating
we've already contacted the Information
Commissioner we'll be putting in a
fuller report to them and we've spoken
to the company that supplied who
themselves have put out a statement
apologizing for the error that they made
this will affect people where some of
his guests or already news somebody's
email address and was able to therefore
log in that has there so it'll be a
limited number of our delegates here but
we are contacting the delegates that
comes to out salon to them exactly what
has happened and what they can do about
that so but any bridge is a serious
bridge that's why we are fully
investigating it and are taking it very
seriously can you say it's a limited
number of delegates but these are some
potentially very important people
affected I mean the Foreign Secretary
for example is the former foreign
secretary one of them and I mean who's
responsible for it and how many people
are actually talk to you about well I'm
not I can't get into the details at the
moment in terms of the numbers do we do
in that investigation the moment working
with the company who supplied the app
who supply companies like Barclays and
Nissan and eBay for conferences and
things around the world but it is
serious any breach of data services why
we are taking is to say within within
finding out about this issue yes do
within half an hour we had fixed this
problem the company had shut that
security issue down so yeah he's now
functioning fully properly and securely
there are a number of Delegates where if
somebody logged in who already knew
their email address they would have been
able to see the photograph the email
address that they use to log in and if
it was there a mobile phone number and
that's happened that has affected a few
people as you've rightly outlined and we
are working with all of the delegates of
Commons to let them know exactly what
has happened you see it it it's easy to
be able to talk about this is like you
know an embarrassment but actually it
could be serious couldn't it you and I
both know how toxic a political
discourse can be at the minute you know
people in the public how I get raped
threats and death threats on Twitter I
mean can you look me in the eye and say
that those threats and not now can be
sent to somebody's mobile phone number
because someone's happen to guess their
email address well as I say we are
working with all we're working all the
delegates of Congress we do a full
investigation to see what exactly and
who exactly was able to be accessed in
this way they say so you had to already
have their email address they
unfortunately be able to go in like this
but for some for some people yes you can
and actually one of the things we have
got to be careful that in our society
and I've talked about this a lot over
the last few months is that ability to
have proper robust debate but with
respect without that kind of hard abuse
that we are seeing I would argue for
many on the hard left particularly on
social and digital media now security
issues in the drifty by as I say these
I'm not for a moment any breach is
anything other than serious that's why
we are taking seriously it's why we deal
with it
within half now being aware of it
yesterday that's why the company has put
its statement out and we will be putting
a full reporting with an investigation
into the Information Commissioner's
Office did you consider resigning at the
moment I focused on making sure that
conference goes well that the attendees
have a really good conference but
yesterday we got that app sorted as
quick as we possibly can and we get to
the bottom of exactly how that happened
and why I happened ok let's move on to
things I'm sure you'll perhaps
uncomfortable talking about which is the
message that you're going into this
Conservative Party conference with
because what we've seen in the in the
last week or so is a whole range of
conservative MPs effectively coming
forward and saying you're not offering a
distinct enough vision took compared to
labor I mean the list I hear some gamer
Liz trust Jacob Riis morg
Robert Halfin pretty betrayal Boris
Johnson all spoken out so can you tell
me what is the distinctive message that
these MPs can go out and sell on the
doorstep well there's a couple of things
I would say to that first of all I think
one of the strengths of the Conservative
Party's that we are and do have this
great wide team a fan of people with
buzzing with ideas and you'll see a lot
of that this week of Commerce as the
government itself will also be outlining
our ideas and our plans for the next
period of time in government to take our
country forward in a really positive way
and actually that's in big contract what
is what is the distinct
what's to say I think two things that I
think that is in big contrast what we
saw last week was old hat ideas that
actually would have fit pensioners
really damage pensioners in terms of the
equity proposals we would the changes in
corporation tax would affect jobs but we
as a party will be outlining this week
is about how we want to make sure we are
giving opportunities to people a good
education the chance to benefit from
more jobs in our economy to have job
security and the investments we're
making in both infrastructure and in our
public services you see I ask for the
distinctive master budget and the things
that you listed there I think that most
parties could probably say right now you
know we want to give it good and
education and want to give opportunities
know what is distinct offering I think
there's a very big difference between us
and the Labour Party Sting's what is
distinctive is these are things we are
doing and we are outlined in very firm
plans about how to take them further
into the future not things that can't be
forwarded not things that can't be
delivered things we are doing the things
we can do in the future to make things
what is that distinctive vision what it
is about making sure we are providing
the things that matters to people every
day about make sure they do get a good
education we're building more homes for
people to be able to act in a home of
their own for them and their family to
make sure we are investing in our NHS in
the long term to make sure it continues
to be a world leading health service
that is how we invest in our public
service and the biggest investment
program in our infrastructure and our
roads and all that we've seen in a
generation making sure we get in our
country ready and fit for the future I
just want to have a look at what Robert
Hoffman said in particular he wrote he's
an MP for Harlow the problems for the
Conservatives is at the Corbin
description of what's going on resonates
with millions of people failing railways
increased homelessness families
struggling despite working every day our
infrastructure under strain high streets
closing crime on the rise oh and all the
things these things are true aren't they
can you really say that people's lives
are better now compared to when you
first came into power eight years ago
yes there's maybe two million more
children getting good an outstanding
education than 2010 there's about a
thousand new jobs a day being created
since 2010
for housing we have actually increased
labour left us with a lowest level of
house building psa's about 1923 about
75,000 homes a year we're back up to 220
thousand and rising so we are delivering
and getting onto that ship every we want
to build a 300,000 homes a year we're
investing more in our NHS than ever
before so yes we are doing those things
we've also got to make sure we take the
opportunity of a week like this to be
just talking about that explaining why
that is good and why it's delivering
things for people as opposed to Labor's
promises that just can't deliver and
often as we've seen in the last year
they then renege on later anyway what
one in the polls you're announcing a
policy to say aren't you around housing
the strategy to what just well what
we've recognized these people have said
for some time that they get frustrated
particularly in our cities in summer
night London but people from overseas
will come in and buy properties when
actually they want to see British people
hire new people in the UK having first
option on those properties so what we're
doing we've already changed but also the
properties have to be advertised here in
the UK but for people overseas people
are not UK taxpayers will pay an extra
stamp duty we're going to consult on the
figure but around 1% we're going to
consult to see if that's the right
figure and the money the income from out
that comes to gun will go into ruffs
leaving help me some of the most
vulnerable people in the country you
spoke a bit earlier about how you're
hoping that you can be able to talk
about the sort of domestic vision if you
like does it worry you sometimes that it
feels that all the kind of band width is
taken up by brexit in the minute I mean
that's fine for obvious it's very
important six months towards leaving the
EU but for you you're in charge of
getting bodes it's not really the most
exciting thing to be selling on the
doorstep asset well bricks it is as you
say it's a huge issue for our country
one of the biggest projects the
government has undertaken of any type
since its probably the second world war
and it is hugely important that we get
this right that we get the deal with the
European Union that delivers to the
country and respects the referendum so
there is a big issue and the media and
people around the country are interested
in that but what we saw this year in the
local elections where we had a really
good set of results and what you'll see
it comes this week is us talking about
what happens after bricks it as well
that domestic agenda as I say delivering
for people in their lives every single
day now and you mentioned the local
election so we stated well obviously the
last general election was a bit of a
disappointment for you and to say the
least
Labour say they are on an election
footing they're ready to go are you
ready for an election when I'm working
local elections for 2019 the next
general election is 2022 it might come
that was that like are you are you ready
to go if there was an election earlier
I'm not working hypotheticals the
election we are working on the next
election is the local elections next
year the general election is 2022 and no
we didn't get the result we wanted last
year but we did show in the local
elections this year when Labour said
they were going to win pretty much every
council seat I think certainly in London
if not the country actually Labour
didn't do that
we had the success in the local
elections this year making gains all
over the country taking back control of
a counselling from Labour in London in
Barnet and actually Labour didn't win
any of those council so I think we
showed in those elections that we can
but do that job we can win those low
collections but that was just stage one
there is a big piece of work for us to
do and we've got big local elections
next year we'll Tereza mainly the
conservators into the next general
election I hope she will and I think she
would yes because this is the Prime
Minister's bringing our country together
I getting that deal with the European
Union I'm confident we will get a good
deal with United Kingdom and the EU that
delivers on the referendum delivers for
our economy in the future and with that
strong domestic agenda delivering for
people right across our country I think
that's a powerful message to go into the
next general election with and now while
we've got to you I want to ask you about
Sky's campaign for an independent
commission to see leaders debates the
general elections is that something
you'd welcome well I'm not yet seen too
many times where Krang goes and
commissions has given us the perfect
answer to everything I think we've got
to look at where we are at the general
election look at what is happening in
the country and make a decision at that
point at the same time though you know
the whole point of having an independent
commission is to take it out of the
hands of politicians and also the
broadcasters so that it's you know an
independent body working out the details
that's got to be a good thing that's not
what I think I wanna see more democracy
well I sure do and that's what the
general election itself is about people
going out and voting based on the
information they get from their local
candidates well they get through the
national media the social and digital
media I think will be increasing in the
next election possibly to the point
where overtakes many other things if
we're looking for four years down the
line so I think we do need to look at
this much near the time and take a
decision based on what is happening in
media across the country you're not
ruling out that you think it could be
good
I'm not ruling out I'm not ruling it in
either I think we need to look at where
we are a Pitney over time okay Brandon
Lewis thanks very much